As ego driven individuals, we love to think
that the universe is all about us.
That we are at the center and everything that
happens, happens because the universe has
some divine plan for us.
We are compelled to believe that the universe
personally cares about us.
Otherwise, what is the point?
How can we care about the universe if it does
not care about us?
But just because we need it to care, does
not mean that it does.
The universe or a god, as some might view
it, is not a human, nor does it function like
one.
It does not experience emotion or empathy.
And it does not care about the ways in which
humans perceive and experience what it is.
It functions objectively.
And therefore, fundamentally, things do not
happen for a reason.
They happen merely because of the arbitrary
alignments of time and space.
Mere coincidence.
But then why does it so often seem that when
things happen, they happen for a reason?
That every time something happens to us, it
leads to some purpose in our life.
That even when bad things happen to us, they
can end up leading us to good things.
Certainly there must be a reason why the cliché,
“everything happens for a reason,” is
so widely popular.
The real reason is because of the resilience
of human nature and the power of our imaginations.
Things appear to happen for a reason not because
the universe or a god-like figure is watching
over us, playing us like a prewritten video
game, but because as humans, we have the power
to MAKE things happen for a reason.
When things happen to us, we assimilate them
into our life and give them a reason for being
there.
We perceive the alignments of time and space
and attach narratives and purpose to the things
that occur.
We are the writers of our own story.
For every moment we experience, we have the
ability to write our own meaning.
For every conflict we face, we have the ability
to write our own resolution.
We can learn, adapt, and create purpose out
of the randomness of life within the universe.
And in my opinion, that is even more comforting
than the idea that things happen for some
ulterior reason.